welcome to winners Wednesday I finally
managed to get you guys on
after months of persuasion why did you
and say why did you not want to come on
the winds Wednesday so bad
so um not that I didn't want to we
didn't want to but because I we wanted
to be a hundred percent sure that we are
financially free from knowing you yeah
well we didn't want to add up existing
properties prior to knowing you okay so
we wanted to make sure that from knowing
you going forward and that we are
financially free from then on from crash
program for the yeah and all you and
Zach cause you are we got there so
basically you just wanted time to see
the money coming in the bank each month
yeah
to make sure that it was completely
certain yeah I know how much you guys
Nigerian culture as well from from from
from either your background your family
you like to say exactly as it is
completely Tegrity so get that when we
first met at the crash course what
happens like from what we learned from
the crash course we just run with it and
we are designers porketta me on that day
same day and so when we make on a
one-to-one literally two weeks after
isn't it we secured our first essay yeah
following what you taught us yeah one
week afterwards but then and I had to
look at the birds in the building do it
without art I say so unfortunately that
fell through
yeah but then I think I was on open rent
and I'll just was that I need to secure
this though I mean I was so pumped from
off your Pascal's I literally
implemented what I learnt from your
questions even though you were exhausted
when you got to the crash course you
arrived in the crash course
you were on the front row asleep like
sleep deprived I stopped the whole event
I went hold on folks
I walked down came up on my hands on
your knees and said hello yes but you
know what you did not know she arrived
from abroad that very morning Wow where
from from Nigeria so you came from
Nigeria came straight to the crash
course before you sleep yeah at the time
I've never thinking this person will
never be financially free because you
didn't know him then yeah how can you
sleep in the crash course well I didn't
know you come from Nigeria was hired
yeah
I literally picked her up from the
airport straight day yeah so you quit
your job two weeks no she quit her job
even before the crash closed even before
yeah what how well because I just said
you know if I don't give a hundred
anything I do in life I don't cut
corners I give it a hundred and ten
percent
there's me and I knew that in order for
me to make it I have to give him a
hundred and a million percent into it so
I I didn't see myself like I'm going to
be working and doing it I didn't think I
would I would have done it properly yeah
I would have given it because property
as you well know it requires a lot of
your time it does but that's very risky
I personally would never advise that
yeah I know um Jenna tell me a bit about
the background because when we had our
one-on-one honor there were six people
we were chatting I was getting to you
guys in a personal level after you
joined the Academy and you taught me a
little bit about the back story and the
reason behind and it was it was quite an
emotional time I mean I was almost in
tears you were emotional you know and
your love for your mom really came out
and how hard she's worked and stuff like
that so give me a little bit background
to your life before getting into
property my life before getting into
property I wouldn't say it was any
different from now I would say this that
my mom stopped working
hard as she stood with my mom she's a
nurse that she was breaking her back
trying to provide us with the lifestyle
that we currently have
so now after now after that we've
secured ideals secured our properties
she's got more time on her hands her mom
has a back I mean I don't that literally
used to dick exactly some sort of
analgesia literally every night yeah
been living tableau because your back
was in so much pain
yeah and was what that was a result
Jenny you thought of being a nurse
constant everything by now how did that
make you feel because you were like
broken yeah I was down I'd seen my mom
in pain that nobody wants see their mom
in pain yells it was it was
heartbreaking but look she's smiling now
she's healthier now and and and do you
think that says as a result of the hard
work that you've put into property
absolutely paid oh yeah without a doubt
so if you don't want me asking how much
income a human now making from property
as a result of my training okay as a
result of your training you want to go
for it we're making right now as a
result of you training almost 10,000 per
10,000 pounds a month Wow impressive and
is that better than you thought same as
you thought you know I I so much
believed you because you are so
motivational and everything you said I
never doubted it yeah I just said like
she will tell you so is his sister my
motto my family motto is anything
anybody can do it so can you see that is
my motto in life
another one is never ever say I can't do
it don't ever give up you need to try
it's going to be tough
but you need to keep trying yeah because
you will succeed
mmm so those are the two things that
have given to my girls in life don't
give up keep trying yeah it's incredible
what you've done in such a short space
of time and you know what
it's so funny because it's it's
difficult sometimes for people like me
to be able to tell the difference
between people that are dreamers and
people were actually a doers and I
remember when we first met you know the
crash course and stuff like that and I
remember I remember on TN say saying to
me I'm gonna training and put the work
in but I hear that all the time you know
and and and I'll never know for 100%
like I try and believe in everybody but
seeing just in the last how many months
ago was that six months six months yeah
seen six months and now you've got just
sure what nine thousand nine a half
thousand just if you'll run around it
like today but nine seven yeah ma ma ma
okay so like yeah yeah ten thousand -
hundred pound or whatever okay but but
whatever it is but making making that
much money a month and is that actually
what that's hitting the bank it's coming
in that's what's coming in profit yeah
because we have HMOs we have these
options and wait wait a second in on my
own house following your everything you
taught us and knowing so much with the
being in academic with all the trainings
going on so we went I went and converted
my put an extension next to me and that
is renting us that's like single late
that is mocking us it's hundred a month
wow that's incredible so what what's
what's that what do you think the key
differences are to people that are
successful and people that aren't
successful what's the what's the
different the differences I would say
the first thing is surrounding yourself
of other people that are successful any
successful person that's hanging around
with losers and I I'm not a loser so how
would I wanted to marry exactly so I
definitely surrounding yourself and
other people that are success yeah and
also education like invest in your
definitely that when people asked me how
to do this how do I that I was recently
talking to one of my friends is like how
did you start your own company at such a
young age like I want to start my own
I said literally you need to invest in
yourself go for the training if you
don't educate yourself it's not gonna
work out yeah say how old are you Jenna
I'm 22 now 22 fantastic so I mean what's
it like do you ever feel like you have
to pinch yourself because six six eight
months ago and seven months ago whatever
it was working as a nurse long hours
breaking you back now making ten
thousand pounds a month in property
living a much better life do you ever
feel like pinching yourself we are
because not just what we making but
within the very short space of time I
mean if I married in a year then I would
say wow but making it in six months yes
we are
we're really saying this is not
happening so it makes you want to go
more and more go more and we are great
no reason that you didn't want to come
home winners Wednesday was because after
three months when you were making loads
of money I was like oh wow
come on winners Wednesday yeah do you
think it was you were thinking I can't
quite believe it yet it needs to sink in
and I wasn't even thinking about that
what I was thinking about was in my mind
it needs to be from knowing you yeah
it doesn't need to be so when now we
were making that my biggest problem was
camera I'm a very you evil in my sound
huh are you for real I'm very I'm a very
reserved woman when it comes to all
these social media thing yeah I'm not in
your era so I'm very I rather stay at
the background and kill it without
anybody knowing yes that's me yeah so
when you say camera I said oh no camera
oh no no no I don't know so that was my
biggest challenge and what changed why
did you agree to Commission
yeah because you're on the eviction what
what changed
being on addiction addiction is oh
you're all surrounded with cameras and
all that so it's like okay so now that
I've put myself as far as that what is
we now some Wednesday yeah I need to go
and tell other people especially single
mothers out there who are struggling
like I did when they were younger don't
rely on anything they'd benefit all
because I knew if you that are doing
instead benefit go and don't rely on it
go and do something you'll be surprised
I've actually told people in my
neighborhood come and speak to me I'm
happy to help ya help you with anything
and recommendations give them my name
give them the name of my company yeah
just to help someone
yeah that's great yes how about you
Jenna what's the what's the what's the
kind of journey being like and what of
their been the key lessons in the last
six months I said in the beginning it
was really hard cuz I had a lot of noise
yeah at I'm like and the rudeness but so
when you were trying to get deals yeah
the agents than the landlords and
vendors were saying know they'll be rude
to you yeah especially her because you
know she's young so they're like the
duck
they don't take her seriously yeah so
but when I'm there the attitude changes
yeah but when she's there alone because
I don't know because of because of the
see that she's young so they're like
probably where have you got the money
from to do to do deals with us
everything yeah but when we get together
everybody's happy to sit down and and
and talk so you found Jenna going out
you were getting a lot of rejection you
still get rejection or do you think your
confidence is grown or what's happened
well since all those knows I didn't let
that get me down a lot of people would
but I use that that energy
am i I don't give up I called up every
single any landlord home country opening
I called them up and then one of them
till one of them which was our first our
RSA though she called me up and she
asked me questions she grilled me how's
that cool would you want to know and I
said every single one of them and then
she got back to my mom she's like who's
that maybe that I just spoke to oh
that's my youngest daughter she was that
Wow I am shocked yeah he's very good I
know I groped her bar she asked every
single one of my questions perfectly and
I think just I'll tell don't they let
the meds get you down literally because
they let me get a lot of meds in the
beginning but now yeah anyways why do
you think you're not getting any knows
now when you used to get so many
probably because of our reputation
because we've got a lot of that proof to
back ourselves up in the beginning we
didn't have we did anybody have much yes
so now we can leverage off of that look
this is what we love that I know I also
as well the fact that this lady said
Jenna Jenna knows what she's talking
about when you know what you're talking
about I think confidence comes with
knowledge absolutely because if you just
go having it go for it and you know what
to say you got other scripts yeah how
can you be confident absolutely very
well said Samuel because in all honesty
our very first right to rent a say she
found it not me yeah I was out there
pursuing leads and when I came back she
said mom I think we're going to secure
our first rent I said what happened so
she told me what she's just said that's
fantastic and the landlady run us back
because she said um no she we run her
back because she said the landlady said
when I come back she should call her
back so when she did when she called her
back she said I'm really sorry I did
grill your daughter but she is good good
stuff so I'm very happy to hand over my
house yeah fantastic
another thing I want to say because we
we agreed as family we are three
Genevieve Hasini our sister and myself
so she doesn't she's like me she doesn't
like all these you know publicity she
stays in the background and she does all
everything she runs everything so now
what what happened there was the
landlady called we call the landlady
back and she said yes she's happy to do
give us our property and now so what we
did now when it went live we sent her
the picture of the apartment how we
turned her apartment around yes she was
shocked she she ran me to say are you
sure this is my apartment
I know is bad by me I can see the
kitchen I can see that's Josefa I don't
believe it was the way you furnish their
address there it just looked completely
different place absolutely that's cry
yeah and and then what is happening now
she actually she actually rang us to say
she's got another property okay so he
wants me working on now she ran off yeah
yes where's your height you know it
amazing that foot had had for sure and
what about your lease option agreement
they're all in hurt for sure so you're
all your properties we have a chair from
AC why did you choose Hartford sure
because the proximity can help with
because we're seeing what we what we
went through we say in blaming up so
there was a lot of starting off there
were lot of running around so in that
lease it all is ok now but initially
there was a lot of running around and so
we just decided we're not going to do
maybe we will go I mean like I mean like
right now we're looking at a 10 bedroom
property in Dobby yeah so now that we
know what more of what we're doing and
everything we don't mind expanding yeah
but initially when we made you know it
make sense to keep your patch closed on
I know the area it's supposed to drive
to what about the lease option agreement
then how did that come about
well we saw the lead in a newspaper
estate agents shop window in our local
area yeah so I went in and inquire and
they said landlord will show you round
so was they were they advertising just a
normal sale yeah okay yeah said landlord
will show you around so booked viewing
we went landlord showed us around so
when we finished he didn't look a very
healthy man and he didn't look very
happy
so I said are you okay and he was almost
in tears when I said are you okay that's
all that I said and I said sit down he
actually invited me to sit down I went
alone so I sat down and he told me he
said he wouldn't have thought in this
stage in his life that he would be going
through divorce and so it just wants to
sell the house and you know just move on
because this is he doesn't want to live
in the house because it's bringing too
many bad memories for him yeah so when
he said that I
I'm sympathizing with this situation
bodies at the same time I said this is
my opportunity to negotiate for a lease
option so I said to him I'm very sorry
to hear that
so boy do you know that you don't need
to sell you don't really need to sell
here you don't need to sell the house
and you don't need to live here if you
don't want to if you don't if you're not
going to leave you where are you going
to leave you said he's got other
properties in London and where his
family is nearer to his family I said so
that's why you want to say he said yes I
said how about if I if I were to tell
you
the amount you want to sell come in five
years time I'll give you more and right
now I will take your property manage it
for you put tenant in there will be
giving you money every month come in
five years time I'll add more money for
what
you're going to buy now and he looked at
me he said no you can't do that I said
yes I can do you know what it I don't
want you to tell anything do me one
favor let these be between you and I no
agent and I'm not going to charge you no
fees you pay agencies don't you he said
yes I said I'm not paying you no fees
free of charge
get the land in spruce up the house if
you're willing to meet with me do one or
two things leave the race with me I said
this is my number speak with your family
and get back to me that was it pretty
much to the tail of what we teach on the
DFA thanks to you because I never ever
knew prior to meeting you all that I
knew was by to net which is what we did
yeah only by Tony how many points let's
the job before before you met me
we had three three biters and how much
money were you making profit from
property then we were making about two
and a half turn off grands yeah so you
were making decent money already
yeah but obviously you've got a family
to provide for you you've got how many
kids I've got two girls mother like ten
because expensive so so your living
expenses were what about were there
about five thousand a month yeah I
remember every ten right so you were
getting a couple a couple grand from the
property's a couple grand from your work
yeah about five grand in total yeah
which was just enough to make ends meet
living in half for sure it's not a cheap
place no sir but but now now you've
learned you don't need lump sums people
think you need 50 grand to buy a house
you know you don't know you don't so
this lease option agreement then that
you got you this isn't your only lease
option you've also got another lease
option that you said I do you've got to
lease options so this one what are the
kind of figures how much are you buying
it for and how much will you be making a
month on
so it was going for 105 yeah and I told
him I will give you a hundred and
fifteen in how long in five years in
five years in which point it will be
worth way more of course and where is it
do I mention the place you can be a just
give me the area okay hey what does back
porch is bar yeah very nice yes but he
was a rundown property okay I really
wonder how much you having to spend on
it we've been about 8,000 8,000 turn it
up so you've already lifted the value oh
yeah and how much you renting out for
about five to five four three far as
we're doing it we added the conservatory
we married dining kitchen oh good
- five times three how much five - five
times three that's your profit no five
to five is rent
yeah per month yeah so what are we
paying the landlord is 650 to five yeah
times three - 650 okay is your profit
that's what we're making in that
property okay two of them okay that's
great fun so you're in the year in the
green yeah you wouldn't be worth you'd
be yeah right what's been your biggest
achievement Jana that's a good question
for me because when most focusing on I'm
just focusing on yes not lease options
and HMOs not yes yes yeah because that
was that was the main strategy that I
wanted to go because that was the main
strategy that I did most of the research
on yes that that was that that was my
target so I say my biggest achievement
to date will secure in all their says
that we have currently yeah yeah
definitely
when I tell people that oh yeah by my
own property management company that one
don't believe it yeah and I like that
surprise I like that surprise element so
yeah definitely that and she's been
sending a lot of her friends to you yeah
I appreciate - oh yeah because
you know what the thing is this often
happens I'm doing what I'm doing because
I'm on a mission to try and help people
have a better life and you know you guys
know that because you've worked really
closely with me yeah of course we have
to charge for the advanced training
otherwise it would be a charity and also
here's a thing if you teach people for
free you seriously never value it I'll
teach people free to a point yeah
and then if the people want serious
mentoring and coaching and stuff like
that they pay for it but the great thing
is when I see my students like you guys
becoming financially free making 10
grand a month and then on a mission and
want to have a rippling effect and a
bringing people to the crash course
oh yeah and and coming on this show
because the reason the real reason
you're on the show is because you want
to inspire people Oh without a doubt
jellow the single moms indeed and single
dads - yeah single because there are
quite reasonable not reasonable
respectable single dads doing amazing
work just like we women are doing yeah
so is to encourage everybody that
regardless of what your situation might
be now yeah please please please keep
pushing don't give up pushing comedy
crush goes somewhere leads is free two
days it is and here's the thing right
most people the government the education
system they want people to be poor and
people say about that they're skeptical
of me I want people to be rich
absolutely that's my Jeff I want to be
rich too I am rich I want other people
to be rich indeed that's my motivation
yeah people think always it a scam no no
no I'll tell you what what's the scam
having a job where you have a bad back
yeah working until you're 65 and then
retiring broke with not enough money to
live and then come back coming back to
work other colleagues of mine so old
honestly I'm not God is listening so oh
they cannot even work there
actually bending and some of the
patients are actually laughing at them
act like they're coming to look after
Ross that who is the patient yeah that
is sad it's very sad and they should not
love Shambala but that's a scam
absolutely I agree and I just said no
way absolutely going to university and
paying forty thousand pounds to study
art to then get a job at McDonald's yeah
that's a scam absolutely like and then
you have learnt that little to pay back
yeah exactly
who is this gamma yeah yeah what would
you say to the skeptics because there's
a lot of them you know people people see
people will think that there'll be
people watching this your story that
thing I it's not true don't believe it
please someone never ever paid us or bet
us or bullied us into doing this this
I'm a Christian this is real this is
real folks come to several crash course
please
that is where it all started that is my
lifestyle not mine I couldn't care less
about mine but seeing my girls lifestyle
just makes me so thankful to God and and
smile yeah so I want everybody to be
like that yeah crash course free
wherever is happening you are so you got
sex to make go yeah I was just gonna say
to all that the people that are
skeptical because I'm not gonna lie I
was a bit skeptical as well because
people would tell me arts a scam I did
they're just rub your money just take
him money just want to get the rich blah
blah blah I would say it just come along
for yourself because if I hadn't come
along I'd be where they are sitting on
the couch saying it's a scam blah blah
blah blah so just like come along and go
from there yes still figures a scam
that's your business but I came along
thinking it was a scam and look at me
now absolutely she's being very honest
became yeah when I said when I said she
should come she said oh mom please
you're not going to mommy that who are
you going to spend your money these
things are not true I said
so do you want your mom to go in noon
and when I said that she said no that's
it
Oh mom I just come and support you but
but please please don't don't don't
party with your money mommy these people
are stop us yeah yeah yeah yeah and
people think that because because
they're because we've been brainwashed
that if something sounds too good to be
true that it is yeah
but the thing is if you think like that
if you think if some it sounds too good
to be true than it is then nothing good
will ever come your way yeah if it does
come true whether it be a good
relationship yeah you're gonna sabotage
it yeah because of you little voice
saying if it sounds too good to be true
it is yeah so what can I just say
something please I need to be honest in
everything that we do we do like in our
first essay our very first guest husband
and wife they actually came spend
Christmas with us in our essay and then
they left and then they forgot 200
pounds cash in ten pounds notes they
went having Christmas drink and water
view and that is kept they forgot that
they had left money in the next room
that they did not use they only used it
to put their clothings so when they
weren't living they just put on their
clothings and left 200 pounds underneath
a lampshade
so as we even though the room was not
used was being us we were cleaning
everywhere regardless so as I shook off
thing and lifted the lampshade to clean
there was money falling down the floor
and I'm like this this is the money they
our first guest no doubt so we called
him up this is I think two weeks after
death Chetta we called him up and said
did you [ __ ] you did forget money and I
said no we didn't I said yes you did and
when he said okay when my wife comes
back ask her to call you cut the long
story short she call us and which
already said oh my god
yes when they came back she took out
money I said how much was it she said a
lot of money I didn't count but in ten
pounds nuts I said okay that's your
money
I left it there and she thought that as
her husband put bucket Rosa that he got
there can be money yeah he did it so and
I said okay this is your money these let
us know your send us your bank details
and we'll send it through and they have
sent so many people to us as a result of
that Wow a lot of people would not do
that
I said no we're running a very honest
business yeah so everybody coming to us
be rest assured that if you left your
PIN in there you get back your PIN they
were so impressive went on booking.com
and give us it's exactly a beautiful
review it's a great story because I
think that when you you could you reap
what you sow yeah and if you cut corners
or if you try and yeah if you if you
give someone a product whether it be a
room or whatever and don't deliver yeah
they will always come back to me and
that's what my philosophy the same as
yours with your apartments under-promise
over-deliver always be honest ethical
and you'll always come back absolutely
and for everybody watching this your
show and something else I want to put
out there or less you are prepared to
work hard
yeah it's not going to happen yeah it is
hard work nobody don't allow anybody to
tell you otherwise
so long as you out there prepared to put
in hard work this is your shoe
absolutely and you've got to work smart
as well not just hard like yeah because
you can put in all the hard work but if
you're not working like oh yeah
absolutely
and when we give people the tools and
teach them what to do and what you say
yeah but people you got to do it yeah
you know in addition yeah the crash
course and
or training it's not a magic wand it's
here's what to do here's what to say
let's do it yeah but you've got you've
got to work for sure absolutely
did you have a lot of money to invest
when you started in this in this
business with me honestly yeah yeah we
did
yeah which helped yeah we had we had
over thank you okay
but still to turn thirty thousand into
ten thousand a month yeah yeah is is
very very impressive
yeah some of your deals you've used some
money there have been others way you
haven't had to use my money you know we
know like even a second of padua we
secured because we had a long time long
long if you stop booking if you were
starting all over again from scratch
yeah yeah with no money yeah
do you think you could have chief
financial freedom now yes because we
know knowledge is power with the
knowledge you've impacted us with you
very doubt if you were spying all over
again from scratch on the financial
freedom challenge you've done lease
option agreement HMOs rent to rents
what would be your first strategy what
would be what would you go and do for me
probably hates fries really but if you
had no money how would you how would you
do it at least option yeah so your
strategy if you've done all over hm out
Bank but even with the even with the
money that we had to start off with we
just made it
Marybel to ourselves that we're not
going to source any property yeah yeah
we don't sauce no property all that
properties direct from London
oh you mean you're not going to pay
people to yeah what did you what did you
decide to do that because it makes sense
to me at all like I rather use that
money and you of my essay beautifully
yeah
then paying somebody money and then no
it just didn't
make sense twice great because firstly
you don't learn exactly secondly you get
people secondhand deals yeah and thirdly
often it often ends in disaster
I know like you know we put so many
horror stories yeah you're better off to
invest in the education indeed do
yourself absolutely and that's what from
the moment from the word go
I said to my girls we are not sourcing
however long it takes
we know sourcing yeah sources as in
paying yes awesome yes no and you've not
done that you've done them all yourself
none of our properties yeah what would
be the greatest piece of advice you
would say to someone that was trying to
go out and start from scratch make sure
you're complying yeah because that's
what we did yeah we were even before we
secured the first one we were fully
compliant with everything so we even
secured a yes but then I mean when I did
the financial freedom challenge I
started out compliant with a bank and
all that yeah but the thing is our great
is the first thing for sure but the
thing is even if you're compliant yeah
if you've got all the kit but you don't
know how to do it go and let go and go
and get the knowledge the education in I
think the first thing I would say is
invest in yourself first like with it
that's what we did because even though
we knew or that we knew was single lates
you don't know nothing else yeah
all these this option hm I'm like wait
what
you know we lit it from new teaching us
yeah and without us investing in
ourselves through you you being our
mentor there is no way some people might
read books YouTube and do it everybody
is different there is no way I would
have read books or YouTube and go and do
it you know way and having even if I
were to go and get education if I did
not get education from a mentor like you
who is so passionate who is so
motivational who is so
which with knowledge and impact occurs
with that knowledge we would not do it
yeah so that you know the fire that you
gave us after the crash progression my
family I thought of my family my my
sister in America said it's not snow
damn yeah you know do you fire us up so
much did you think of the crash course
that you'd be sat here like this having
a conversation no we didn't even know
what his we nice always it yeah we know
the hell we did we didn't hear that at
all you know you know I often tell
people that the reason I do training is
my mission it's a business but one of
the reasons is because making it alone
is boring yeah and a lot of my friends
come from the Academy and from the crash
course yeah and I become friends with
them and it's I'm really honored to be
able to call you guys friends look so
well we are so honored I mean who are we
who are we really
we are so honored for you to invite us
to your beautiful home are you kidding
me it's our legs in his house we saw or
not or this is massive was thank you so
much you're welcome thank you and we're
gonna have dinner now Wow you're gonna
get to like you know hangout chat to the
family and stuff I know you've invited
me to your church I will come I will
come but I really appreciate your
friendship and and say you both amazing
people thank you so much I don't think I
could think of people more deserving of
success and I'm just truly honored to be
your mentor and your friend thanks for
coming on the show thank you
you know where that goes of property the
show I always said someone it is my face
love it doesn't matter where whoo-hoo or
that train as I get there is no other
like some elites thank you so much thank
you
bless you guys awesome so I hope you
guys enjoyed that I hope you learned a
lot and we're inspired and you know what
you've got to put the work in it's got a
burn but if it burns and you're prepared
to put the work in I'd love to work with
you at the property investors crash
course there's a link below two days on
the house from me where you'll be
learning
the skills like ensei and Jenna Jenna
did as well so see you next time
god bless you and thank you so much for
watching
[Music]